[Music]
pastor mark the question is uh is it
appropriate for a person to be
re-baptized is it appropriate for a
person to be re-baptized the bible does
tell us about one instance of re-baptism
when should a person be re-baptized well
if an individual has made a commitment
to christ
and they've drifted away from that
commitment to christ
a commitment to christ and his truth and
his church is a public commitment a
person may have drifted away from that
and they decide to come back to christ
rebaptism is appropriate it's not
appropriate every time you sin it's not
appropriate every time you fail because
christ forgives us but if we totally
turn our back on the teachings of christ
totally turn our back on the commitment
of truth totally turn our back on bible
doctrines we go out into the world then
rebaptism is appropriate but there's
another time that rebaptism is
appropriate let me read to you a little
bit about rebaptism here's a group of
people that were baptized by immersion
by immersion but they were re-baptized
acts chapter 19
says it came to pass verse 1 that while
apollos was at corinth paul having
passed through the upper coast came to
ephesus finding certain disciples he
said to them have you received the holy
ghost since you believed they said we
haven't even heard about the holy ghost
he said to them who baptized you what
were you baptized they said john the
baptist then paul said to them john
baptized with the baptism of repentance
saying to the people that they should
believe in christ when they heard this
they were baptized in the name of jesus
so here were people that were baptized
by john the baptist
but they heard they had never heard the
fullness of truth by the holy spirit and
they were re-baptized
there are people who are baptized by
immersion but they never hear the
fullness of truth about death
they still believe in the immortal soul
they never hear the fullness of truth
about the sabbath they still believe in
sunday they come to meetings they hear
the truth of god's word they desire to
be re-baptized you know if god is
leading you in that direction
and you need
counsel in that area if you were once
baptized by immersion but you drifted
far far away went out and broke the
sabbath and went out and didn't live a
mortal life and you want to be
re-baptized put the comment in our in
our comments section here will if one of
our pastors talk with you we'll help you
to understand this even more fully if
you were baptized once by immersion in a
protestant church and you've never
understood the fullness of truth of the
bible and you really want to do that we
will be more than happy to help you to
to have that fullness of that experience
with jesus all right pastor mark thank
you for that answer hey everybody matt
gray here media director for hopeless
365. don't go yet make sure that you
subscribe and click the bell so you get
notified of the next video in this
series and i think you should check out
these other videos over there i think
you'll like those as well see ya